the data that came in over the weekend
all missed analysts estimates which
suggests that analysts are still sort of
overestimating the strength of the
Chinese economy right now then when you
drill down into some of those numbers
the the evidence is even more
discouraging so industrial output 6.1
percent was sort of skewed by very low
numbers last year so that bump is maybe
less than it appears also inflation data
from last week skewed by high pork and
food prices so it does appear there's
sort of gathering evidence that the
economy is worse off than it seems the
key with China is to to try to get some
idea of whether they're going to be able
to change their whole economic model
away from this desire to build stuff
towards one which is more related to
services more related to consumption the
outlook for Europe next say ten years is
actually one of modest growth and to tie
that back to what the market is pricing
right now I can't get my head around the
fact that now people are thinking
China's slowing perhaps at five perhaps
it's at six percent growth or what's
growing who heads the growth coming from
I mean there's so many indicators which
are at minus 10 minus 20 minus 15 you
wonder where what's on the other side to
make it a positive number
consumers in the West actually benefit
from a lot of the bad news that's coming
out around commodities or resources
Chinese devaluation in a sense that's
all good for us consumers in the West so
we've been investing in retailing
companies in the internet service
providers those kind of companies
obviously more expenditures going on the
internet than it is going in Contra
ditional retailing going forward so
we're looking in those kind of areas the
best place to look for value at the
moment this places where you have low
inflation combined with the positive
credit impulse and in other words you
know people are borrowing more and the
economy is going to be fueled by that
credit growth and the two places where
we see that is Japan and Europe I mean
that's why the consensus view among
strategists is to be long Japan and
Europe so I think that dis inflation
theme is a big one I think it's going to
be long last